In previous units, you've learned about the building blocks of GPU computing,
the fundamentals of parallelism, mechanics of writing programs, and techniques for making them fast.
However, one of the challenging things about learning a new programming model
is what happens when you run into a kind of problem you've never seen before.
So what we're going to do in this unit
is look at a variety of interesting problems to solve,
and work through how we might map these problems efficiently onto the GPU.
There's no magic pill that will allow you to instantly think in parallel,
but what I've found helpful for me is to see a variety of problems
and how they map to parallel algorithms and data structures.
It helps me have a little broader tool box of techniques and lessons
that I can use in attacking other problems I may not have seen before,
and I hope the same will be true for you.